[Applause]
a statement of solidarity
protesters at a mural of england
footballer marcus rashford in manchester
which was defaced after sunday's euros
final
rashford's well known for his successful
campaign for more free school meals
during the pandemic
he and two other young black players
received online racial abuse
after failing to score penalties against
italy that was at the heart of
wednesday's prime minister's questions
the labour opposition accusing the
government of using anti-racism as a
political football
the government has been trying to stoke
a culture war
and they've realized they're on the
wrong side and now they hope that
nobody's noticed
why else would a conservative mp boast
that he's not watching his own team why
else would another conservative mp said
might say that marcus rashford spends
too much time
playing politics when he's actually
trying to feed children that the
government won't
boris johnson said he utterly condemned
the abuse and would amend football
banning orders
they're normally used to bar individuals
to take part in for example
racist chanting or hooliganism from
attending matches
now they'll cover online racism while
johnson's put the tech giants on notice
i made it absolutely uh clear to them
that we will legislate
to address this problem mr speaker in
the online harms bill
and unless they get unless they get hate
and racism off their platforms they will
face
fines amounting to ten percent of their
global revenue
johnson refused to say whether he was
wrong not to condemn supporters who
booed the england team
before the tournament for taking the
knee an anti-discrimination gesture
previously he defended the fan's right
to do so and his home secretary went
further at the start of the euros
criticizing the team taking the knee i
just don't support
you know people participating in you
know that type of gesture
gesture politics to a certain extent so
when patel tweeted her disgust at the
racist abuse after the final
england player tyrone mings was furious
writing you don't get to stoke the fire
at the beginning of the tournament by
labelling our anti-racism message as
gesture politics and then pretend to be
disgusted when the very thing we're
campaigning against happens
now some conservative politicians say
the government's getting its messaging
wrong
and needs to reflect on how that impacts
real-life racism
now this man raheem sterling is another
england player who's been on the
receiving end of
racism not just online but at times from
popular newspapers as well
he was included in the team of the
tournament a selection of the best
performers at the euros
his outstanding contribution and england
making the final
may have increased public support for
the team's anti-racism tactics
but the real breakthrough could be when
black players are listened to whatever
they do
or don't achieve on the pitch nadine
barber al jazeera london